you grandma Ethel yeah you know her  yeah we know Ethel she's like a legend  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  this place hasn't changed a bit  where is the queen of the manor I'm  surprised your mother told you anything  about me I can't believe you'd put up  with her all these years  why do you hate her so much oh I don't I  I want you to get to know her you can't  bring me here and expect me to just hate  her like you do  who are you talking to fab  he never did understand  whatever it is you think Ethel did  you've got it all wrong  [Music]  I know what you think I did she really  needed you you know and you're just left  her here all sure you okay yes I'm gonna  die soon  [Music]  you  [Music]  you